Are they lightweight enough?
You guys?
This waffle material from Halara is so lightweight.
It's super easy, breezy.
It always fit very flowy and loose.
There's pockets, so there's tons of space.
It's never choking you in.
I usually wear a size large,
but since I got the elastic bottom version this time,
I wanted them to be a little bit more athletic looking.
I wanted to be able to, like,
run around in the summertime with my kids.
So I got a size small and they still fit amazing.
I'd say the wide leg version definitely feels a little more elegant,
like you can go to work.
There's always a
big time discount for first time uses of the TikTok Shop.
It's linked right here.
If you wanna get a pair of your own,
don't worry about size or color
because there's free shipping and free return.
So just get what you like and see how it fits.